- I know that you just
released your first music video
because I saw it and I love it.
It's so cool.
- Thank you. You watched it?
- I did. I love,
- [Folake] Thank you,
thank you.
- I love even the hero angle
with like the fire going
on in the background.
The hook is so incredibly cool.
♪ Ehen ♪
♪ Okay ♪
- [Folake] Thank you, thank you.
- [Kelly] Yeah. It's so incredibly cool.
I love the storytelling.
I love the, like, the live shots.
It looks almost like
newsfeed, like the air.
- It is. So,
unfortunately, in 2020
there was a shooting, doing a protest,
and a bunch of innocent
protestors were murdered.
And it's questionable who
actually committed those murders
but it said that it was
officials of Nigeria.
So this song, Ehen Ehen Okay Okay.
I shot it in Nigeria entirely.
And I have clips from the
actual protest in there,
and I just wanted to
highlight that that happened.
- It looked like it.
It appeared like that.
- Yeah.
- Ehen Ehen Okay Okay.
- Ehen Ehen Okay Okay. You
have to stay with accent.
- I know. Okay Okay.
- Ehen
- I can't, I'm gonna fail you every time.
- No, you got it! That's it.
- At least I'm consistent.
(laughing)
I love when you come on though.
You're just such a
rockstar as you walk out.
And I love that you're both in
some kind of rock band today.